cuando los talibanes Se tomaron el poder
en agosto de 2021 prometieron que
respetarían los derechos de las mujeres
pero han limitado muchos de ellos bajo
el argumento de que es para respetar la
ley xaria cuéntanos Qué es esta ley y
qué está pasando con las afganas
Bueno buenas noches efectivamente cuando
los tariban llegaron al poder se sabía Y
por lo menos se presentía que esto era
lo que iba a suceder efectivamente de la
charia es la ley islámica se basa en los
preceptos establecidos en el Corán el
problema realmente no es la chaya ni las
fuentes de del derecho mismas de la
jurisprudencia islámica o el fic el
problema Realmente está en la
interpretación una interpretación que
además se mezcla entre mezcla con el
código tribal de la ex mayoritaria en
Afganistán que es la etnia entonces lo
que ha venido sucediendo es un
detrimento progresivo de los derechos de
la mujer como ustedes muy bien lo
mencionaban hace un momento en la nota
donde no solamente se les está quitando
el derecho a la educación empezamos con
el uso de la burca obligatorio pasamos
con el cierre de las escuelas primarias
para las mujeres para las niñas perdón y
luego pasamos ya a la prohibición de que
entraran a las a las universidades Pero
además de esto también se está cambiando
los planes de estudio cambiando Esos
planes de estudio para ser única y
exclusivamente un estudio
de los del islam estudio teológico del
islam y el problema digamos es que
tenemos unas mujeres que no son las
mismas mujeres de hace 20 años aquí
habíamos tenido unos avances en esta
materia y tenemos mujeres que son jueces
que han sido además perseguidas y cuáles
son las consecuencias de que en este
momento las mujeres no puedan ni
estudiar ni trabajar en organismos
humanitarios y que hayan sido despedidas
de posiciones como las que uno usted nos
cuenta de las jueces
Pues mira finalmente lo que vamos a
tener es un retroceso en lo que se había
logrado en términos de avanzar en el
proceso de alfabetización para las
mujeres en este momento en los últimos
informes que había presentado Naciones
Unidas en a principios de este año
precisamente para el día de la mujer se
hablaba de que estábamos estamos
hablando Ya de un veinticinco por ciento
de las mujeres que se están quedando por
fuera de estos sistemas de digamos
rezagadas en términos de Educación vamos
a volver a entrar en un proceso de
analfabetismo para la mujer pero de
hecho hay una cosa todavía más grave que
ustedes también mencionaban las mujeres
tienen que ir a la calle acompañadas de
hombres de sus parientes masculinos más
cercanos y tienen que ir y visitar al
médico y este médico tiene que ser una
mujer en el momento en que tengamos ya
un déficit de mujeres doctoras quien va
a atender a las mujeres y empezamos a
tener el yoga que tuvimos cuando los
talibán llegaron al poder en el 96 que
fue el momento en el que veíamos que las
mujeres afganas morían sin atención
médica Entonces tenemos un retroceso a
todos los niveles para la mujer en
Afganistán